well mother nature's warnings are
becoming increasingly drastic what we
used to call
extreme events are suddenly the norm
infernos in western canada
with temperatures never before
registered we're shocked
and we're horrified but we always it
seems managed to turn away
devastating storm damage in europe too
and more denial so on to the point we
ask
climate catastrophe will we ever change
our ways
[Music]
[Music]
yeah thank you very much for joining us
on the show and with us in the studio
is petra pinsler author and journalist
with the hamburg-based weekly deed
site she's convinced that we will change
our ways
and life will be better also with this
is claudia kempfert from the german
institute for economic research
she argues that climate protection means
freedom across the generations
a fossil-free life is not about going
without
it's about living a fuller life and a
warm welcome to to anjali ramakrishnan
who is with the mercator institute
also headquartered here in berlin and
angeli says
for the global south it's all about
reconciling decarbonization
with justice and poverty alleviation
okay thank you very much for all for all
three of you for being here today i'd
like to take the first question to
claudia
it's got to do with the united nations
which is calling climate change
the defining crisis of our time indeed
un secretary general antonio guterres
says climate change the climate
emergency is a race we are currently
losing however he insists it is a race
we can win
do you share his optimism yeah i share
his optimism because we are now at the
tipping point also in the discussions we
are
at the tipping point related also to
social
participation on the topic we are we
have the fridays
for future movement all over the globe
we have the rulings
for example in germany from the general
court but also in other countries so we
see
we see step by step much faster action
than before
and we have lost a lot of time with
backward discussions the last 15 years
but now we have reached a tipping point
where we can change
but we have to act now we cannot
postpone it to the future
fascinating insights great stuff to
begin the show with that amount of
information
optimistic information to petra you
wrote a book about
how you and your family of four tried to
adopt a carbon
neutral lifestyle how did it go and what
did you learn
well we didn't succeed you didn't
succeed
you failed miserably we tried and the
thing is you
you try you fail and you try again yeah
and we didn't fail on all accounts um
what we did was actually happened out of
frustration we were very frustrated with
the politicians that didn't really act
on the facts that we all saw climate
change is a fact we feel it now
you feel in canada you feel it in
germany we feel all over the world so we
try to find out what we personally can
do
and we went through a whole year and
checked every account of our personal
lives so
clothing traveling the food we eat the
way we live
and we lowered our co2 emissions
from all around 11 tons to seven
which is not actually really good
because we need to go down to two
but there are a couple of things that
you can't change because you live in a
society you can't rebuild your house
from scratch but
we were i think we're in a good way you
you you said in your statements at the
top of the show you we will live a
better life and
you know the optimism that you two are
sharing and maybe you share it too
uh is is f is fascinating to me where
does that optimism come from
because i experienced this personally my
life is better
now than it was before for example um we
had a car we don't have a car now
we live in a city so it's actually
easier than when you live on on
somewhere in a remote area but
it took me about two or three months to
automatically um
go from when i go to work to use the
bike and not the car
so you need a certain time to to to to
to really get used to the different way
of life and now i don't need to go to a
spot studio any longer because i bike to
work and i bike backwards so i have the
sport every day included in my life
which makes my life better
cool wonderful anjali uh i know it's a
big task but try and give me
a summary if you can of how this whole
climate debate is impacting
india um i think it's pretty relevant in
india as it is
anywhere else in the world and i think
it's pretty um it's a very
very strong conversation that takes
place and i think it's also reflected in
the
the sort of the pledge that india made
in the paris 2015
agreement and it was it was achievable
and it can go a bit further
um but the thing is what pulls back and
what maybe restricts the extent to which
india is able to
sort of commit or be able to make the
extra effort is
other priorities that sort of india is
right now leading to achieve with the
growing population with economic growth
not yet at its peak it's got a lot of
space where it's going to consume more
it's going to emit more
and the the ideal sort of a sweet spot
would
be you're able to achieve that
incremental growth or other incremental
consumption but not at the additional
emission
level that we'd hope the images we tend
to see from india are fog and smog in
delhi and it's pretty extreme stuff you
don't come from delhi do you
um i do i i wasn't born there but i
spent
majority of my adult life in delhi and
i've seen it
i haven't been to india for a couple of
years you know it's as bad as it seems
the weather the air is foggy the air is
uh it is hazy it's not clear it's
um the news does not sort of give a
false impression of how pathetic the
situation is
and and there have been efforts it's not
that people aren't doing anything the
government is not up to it
there are targets there are um
objectives that are laid down there are
schemes
but it takes a little more than you know
i think it's a play it's the demand side
play as well as a supply side play
and i think that moving forward i mean
we're not in a comfortable situation
anymore it's sort of getting to the red
line where you know we need to really
act and we need to really put put all
all gears in and i think sort of we
still find in the sweet spot where we're
able to
levy a cost on the extra pollution
that's been done but at the same time
not put consumers in a position where
they can't live a happy life
so i think it's a great example daily i
remember that one of the german
chancellors a long time ago
um made a campaign um where he's
actually said the
the sky about the rule again and it's an
area which
is very industrialized with a lot of
coal mining
and coal plants there and he actually
made the pla
the plight we i want the people to to
have good air quality
so switching from coal to renewables is
is a good way to
increase um the the to to to lead
to give the people a better life um i
mean
i completely agree with you yeah i
completely agree with you but i wish the
answer was that let me just interrupt on
this complete agreement
because you know there's the three of
you and i some of our viewers are going
to
watch this and they're going to say
they've all got the same mindset here
all three of them me too
probably yeah and that mindset is that
climate change is a very real challenge
there are
other people though around the world and
there are plenty of them who think it's
all
made up or it's all harmless uh claudia
what do you say to people like that to
the deniers
to the skeptics well um it's not the
science
uh what those people refer to because
the scientific facts are
clear and since decades are clear that
the human-induced climate change is
ongoing and we already see that right
now with the extreme weather events
for example in canada with a heatwave in
russia with burning forest
in finland right now and the
climatologists tell us
that's that's what we will face in the
future much more often that we
are seeing right now so there are
scientific
findings and the skeptics are also
driven by pr
campaigns based also from the fossil
fuel lobby and there are scientific
studies showing that they are fueling
these pr campaigns in denying and
merchants of doubt so to to see doubt is
their
business model and we have to look to
the facts i'm a scientist
we are scientists so um the scientific
facts are very clear
even without believing in climate change
look at delhi
yeah to breathe good air and delhi even
without believing in
in in the fact of climate change you
want better air it's difficult to look
the other way
but i think i mean in a place like delhi
of course i mean it's definitely not
easy
to be going to work every day given the
air that you're surrounded with
and i think the situation sort of you
could find examples of in london
in singapore where they've had
congestion pricing in beijing
and i i mean the solution there are
solutions existing across the world
where cities have faced maybe to not the
extent to which delhi is facing but sort
of been there and you know
have have efforts and policy measures
that have been put in place and i think
um it's it's a bit of both you have
someone who is say that it's it's
it's on the government they are the ones
who have to make the effort and make
sure the
the the right policies are put in place
we can't be changing our lifestyles
or our routines and where on the other
side it's you know there is a little bit
of a responsibility and
the it falls on the consumers to make
the right choice there is the delhi
metro
cycling is particularly not an option
given it's not lane driving you don't
have bike lanes
but it's not something you can you can't
think of there are
from the metro station to the offices
you have bikes being provided you have
auto rickshaws you have
multiple modes of transport apart from
private transport
but i think um i mean there are there
are many other systemic changes that
needs to come up
before we solely put the effort or the
blame on just the government or just the
consumer
and you can combine all this i mean you
can combine also with climate policy
climate policy creates freedom
for many countries for the future
generations climate
policy also creates a welfare also for
all the people
and increases welfare as well and
climate change is not a
it's not a subject of belief it's really
a scientific fact
and as a scientist i always have to say
that it's not believing into something
it's not a religion it's facts it's
science and that's
where we all clear on and climate policy
help a lot yeah
let's look now at one example of how
interconnected our environments our
habitats and our lives have become
and that example is the massive buildup
of plastics in the world's oceans
and rivers a vacuum cleaner is not
enough to combat plastic waste on south
africa's beaches
millions of tons of plastic particles
are now deposited on beaches all over
the world
the rivers are in fact the arteries of
these countries that transport the waste
from the cities
this also applies to the nile in egypt
here
volunteers are also trying to stem the
tide of plastic
the fishermen are directly affected
i see a lot of plastic plastic bottles
and also
cans all of the trash is ruining my net
and at the same time it's killing the
fish
piles of garbage are accelerating
species extinction and climate change
some materials take several hundred
years to decompose
and will probably never break down
completely
meanwhile awareness is growing about the
threat this poses to humanity
recycling plants do exist but they can
only recycle a fraction of the waste
produced
this is exacerbated by a throwaway
society that has become accustomed to
having its needs met
everywhere at any time in convenient
packaging
should we learn to live without plastic
well that's the question peter i'd like
to just put it a different way i mean we
throw huge quantities of stuff
especially plastics into our oceans and
our rivers
what does that tell us about mankind
humankind
it tells us that we have a problem
that's much larger than climate change
it
is a the problem is the way we deal with
the world
we think the world is just something we
can consume we don't have to get back we
don't have to preserve
and we can have ever more and i think
this is a misconception
to a certain extent we have to kind of
step back and think what we really need
but for 18 months now in my newspapers
i've been reading that there's going to
be a big
rethink a big reset because of the
pandemic and it's changed the way we
think and the way we see the world
especially
the climate issue is it happening is it
going to happen yeah i think there are
tendencies and showing that a lot of
people think over whether this strategy
of just
always more and more and more and also
harming the climate harming the
environment is not a great strategy and
we should
move away and now we are learning with
video conferences we are learning more
cycling but always i mean it's not only
a matter of lifestyle it's also a matter
of transformation
which brings a lot of challenges but
brings also a lot of chances
to all of us but also to the industry
into the system
itself and a lot of new jobs and systems
capitalism versus climate yeah so it's
not versus uh
it's it's both together so in the
original form the economy can do a lot
and the
really classical social social
economics and ecological make
make it together in a certain way social
ecological economics and say say that
way
is an issue which we can do but we have
to price in
the environmental damages we have to
price in also the climate damages
and we have to transform and that brings
a lot of challenges but also huge
economic chances
and angela just let me let me through to
throw two slogans out here green
revolution
d growth
well i mean yes they both are the right
terminology right now given the climate
catastrophe
but um speaking globally i think that
degrowth is something that needs needs a
wider audience needs a wider discussion
needs a wider platform
and right now it hasn't happened yet no
definitely not
it hasn't happened yet i think we're
still
sort of mulling over it there is a huge
clash of scientists
a political scientist that have
considered going forward with it in
terms of research but the real
implementation of it
i don't see the politics the leaders
picking it up to the extent that it
needs to
but if you look at the global south
where you know we've not our
trajectories right now still upwards
we've not peaked we've not
reached the position in terms of
standard of living in terms of
well-being in terms of growth
where we can look at a degrowth but you
still have china
india giving carbon neutral targets by
2050 2060 despite the fact that it was
only
less than two two decades ago that you
know we had a real chance
at at reaching the growth but i mean
having said that i'd also i also think
what claudia said is it's not
capitalism or climate and i think it's
sort of you know working hand-in-hand
because
to be able to address the climate issues
we need money and
we have the fossil fuel industries which
have the money so we cannot be working
towards solutions by putting them down
and
you know be like we need the we need the
oil under the ground
beneath the ground yes we need but we
can't isolate them in our fight and i
think it has to be sort of a
you know a a play together and how to
best find the solution to be able to say
harness
if it's if it's uh renewable energy if
it's all to date audited pricing if it's
carbon pricing we need the other players
on board as well
so we're hearing dirty things need the
dirty things need to degrow
but the good things need to grow and
that's that's the fundamental issue here
i completely agree about this this is
where capitalism
could kick in in a good way it's
financial markets now more and more
leading the change because you don't
want to have stranded assets you don't
want to put your
money into a coal mine these days
because you don't know whether in 20
years it will be still
able to to to be run but who's going to
bear the cost of standard assets do the
governments right now in the developing
nations have the
the the willingness and the financial
strength to be able to bear the cost to
standard assets when they have other
development and national priorities come
into play
so i think that the fact that there is
still a lot of pledges a lot of
targets that are given by the leaders in
the global south is
is enough to say there is an intention
but there has to be a tech transfer
there has to be a financial support
coming
coming at the same time to be able to
make those policies a reality
well in the battle to keep the global
warming below two degrees we've touched
on this already we must slash
global emissions of carbon dioxide by
about 45
before 2030 quite soon so that is all
with the aim
of reaching zero net emissions by 2050
the big question
is how ten years ago
shortly after the reactor accident in
fukushima japan the german government
decided to take all german nuclear power
plants off the grid and switch primarily
to renewable energy sources
german nuclear power will be phased out
in 2022
but the dismantling process is a
difficult one the fuel rods need to be
cooled for years to come
and some radioactive substances will
have to be stored safely for thousands
of years
at this point in time there are only
interim storage facilities
other countries are pushing for a
revival of the controversial technology
after numerous accidents in old american
nuclear power plants
the biden administration plans to build
smaller modern plans
france russia and china in particular
also want to use nuclear power to
satisfy part of their enormous
energy needs the advantage unlike
combustible substances like coal natural
gas or oil nuclear power plants are
largely co2 neutral
and therefore more climate friendly at
least from this particular point of view
do we need nuclear power to stop global
warming
anjali um sorry claudia but i think it's
the closest low carbon option next to
renewables in terms of
providing access to everyone and
yes there are a lot of reservations
there is a cost
associated with it there is high risk
but i think that there is a very less
understanding of
the techno economic effects over over
the public perceptions over the lobby
perceptions of the potential that
renewable can actually have a larger
share
as a low carbon supply system we
disagree
i just agree strongly disagree because
the potentials of renewable energy are
really large especially also for india
and we know solar energy has large
potentials
uh wind energy biomass as well so you
don't need nuclear nuclear as you said
it's too risky it's extremely costly one
generation
uses nuclear power but 40 000
generations have to take care of the
waste
and that's not what we should put to the
future generations
what is the you know where should would
we be looking for the right mix for the
right
for the new technologies where a 100
renewable energy world and
several studies are showing this already
that also india
usa europe can do it i know there are pr
campaigns in favor of the small medium
reactors which is coming from
a startup who wants to create these
reactors it's a powerpoint technology
knowing since the 50s it's not working
it's not economically it's creating more
risk
and also the military issues are here
and point
but the the answer is renewable energy
is the answer and
the potentials are always neglected and
ignored
simply by these pr campaigns and india
has so
large potential so one more argument i
would say nuclear is just not quick
enough
to build all these power plants you need
time and we need to fight climate change
for 30 years yeah yeah so you can put a
um solar everywhere in the remote areas
in in africa
solar can be the solution wind energy is
very
the technology is quite easy so you can
put them wherever
wherever we need them and with with
nuclear
it's it's the other way around it's it's
not quick it's expensive and
no country has yet managed to deal with
the
with the leftovers just one question
peter i mean
[Music]
we need the perspective of the younger
generation and i and i
was thinking about i read about your son
who complained to you he got annoyed
with you because he said that you've
you come from a generation that has
traveled the world
and enjoyed doing so and we now have
completely different expectations about
what i presume
is his generation i think that this is
where the question of justice kicks in
it kicks in between the generations and
it kicks in between
um the north and the global south and
there is a huge issue that we haven't
solved yet it's not the south that
has to go forward it's the north and
it's our generation not the young
generation because we need
to to to let something over when we they
need to have the possibility to inherit
something from this world and i think
it's absolutely right
i'm optimistic here the guardian
newspaper only recently had a big
headline sort of we've had six decades
of these warnings but we haven't heeded
them
we haven't felt the issue now we feel it
we feel it in germany we feel it in
canada we feel it everywhere
and i would say mankind is able to to
quickly when when the problem is there's
one strong argument what i just said
also in the beginning we are the tipping
point because of the civil society
and here's the difference also in the
picture what we see right now
the civil society has changed and this
is what we see in the rulings
of the federal courts also in germany
and the netherlands and the u.s
everywhere and the civil society can and
is pushing
for a change because because we all fear
that there is a
as a lost future and we should change
right now and
i think there is a tipping point now for
movement i agree that i mean
there is the the gen z gen x gen y that
is that is sort of questioning why is it
that we have to push back
our wants and desires to travel to to
consume a little more
but i think that at the same time there
is a lot of awareness in the generation
on what what we're going to be heading
towards and is this the life that we
want for
ourselves in the next 40 50 years um i
think a lot of
information and understanding has sort
of trickled down to schools
into syllabuses into putting into the
the the matter that this the read at
school
so um there is going to be a bit of
pushback because you're essentially
limiting the periphery of how much can
you really want and go out
but i think the generation is a lot more
aware before they take their choices
they take their options you have a lot
of
this younger generation or maybe the the
20s and the 30s
we who have accepted to make the change
in terms of the transport that they use
in terms of the diet they have in terms
of how much they consume what kind of
housing where are they going to live
how much do they travel in the year and
i mean
a lot of it has to to my experience so
far been a european experience for me
um and in india there isn't enough
to sort of complain because it's not
like it's it's beyond control that you
know every month someone's outside
so it's i wouldn't say that there is so
much of a pushback
from the generation i think there's a
lot of acceptance it's going to
take a change there is a bit of sort of
a
a sort of an annoyance that you know
we've come so far yes 60 years nothing's
happened but are we waiting for it to
reach in a post situation to act
but something is going to happen in this
country in the next couple of months
where we have a general election a very
a watershed election i would suggest
at the end of september uh uh half a
minute
from each of you what advice would you
give to the incoming german government
on the climate issue to go forward
quickly because there's lots of markets
for the german industry
if we now switch into into a green
economy if we are able then to provide
green products and debate
we need we really need an honest debate
about the chances but also about the
transformation not only determine goals
that's good they all confirm
but we need measures to go there and
here there's some kind of dishonesty
in the whole debate they can do better
on the carbon pricing
pricing that's one issue i mean yes it's
still an unmet in concrete terms tell me
what exactly you mean
i don't know we've got very little time
but how when you said they couldn't do
better i mean i think the rate at
the rate per unit that's been set right
now is not the limit to which we
actually need to be able to
reach net totality or to be able to meet
the two degree mark by 2050 by the by
mid century
so the debate is at the very early point
very polemic
just saying where the gasoline price is
increasing by whatever
uh five cents or so and the debate is
over
so the carbon price it's really a good
measure but in reality the politicians
cannot make it really
happen and that's the main problem i
think
what we need is a whole mix of of
measures there absolutely agree
but the most important thing is that
they start to put into place measures
and it's not just about
paris and climate goals any longer it's
now time to act i think
the the engineers is absolutely right
and we have the things
we have the the the measures the
technology we can go forward and there
are huge chances
so we really need to talk in the
election campaign about the chances we
have maybe bringing back
into the organization yeah right
opportunities galore we have learned
we've been talking about the
the climate catastrophe how to avoid it
not the catastrophe that has already
arrived
uh we're in a good mood we're hopeful
for the future
and we'd like you to join us again
cheers down
[Music]
[Music]
you